bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans savaugarde ce soir
sommes-nous prêts pour la guerre c'est
la question que vous posez dans votre
dernier livre Jean-Dominique merchef
bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être notre
grand témoin ce soir spécialiste des
questions de défense journaliste à
l'opinion et mauvaise nouvelles vous
démontrer dans cet ouvrage et bien que
la France n'est pas prête à un
engagement majeur et au retour de la
guerre de haute intensité comme en
Ukraine on est à un moment de bascule
stratégique on en parlera vous nous
direz pourquoi oui on a quelques raisons
de s'inquiéter notre grand débat ce soir
à quoi joue François Baayou alors que le
remanimement est attendu dans les
minutes qui viennent le président du
MoDem a renoncé à entrer au gouvernement
faute d'accord profond avec la politique
de l'exécutif faut-il y voir une
mais-entente cordiale ou une véritable
crise politique nous en débattons dans
un tout petit instant avec mes invités
enfin nos affanchi ce soir regard sur le
monde Vincent hugux le billet philo
Pierre-Henri tavoyot et puis Bourbon
Express bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée signé Stéphanie des pierres
voilà pour le sommaire on y va
jeandominique perch ça vous regarde ça
commence tout de
[Musique]
suite alors faut-il parler de crise
politique ou de simple caprice en
refusant d' au gouvernement François
Baayou a donc fait vraiment bruillamment
entendre sa différence et son désaccord
de fond dit-il avec la politique mené
par l'exécutif certes ça n'est pas une
première mais cette fois ce coup de sang
pourrait bien avoir des conséquences
affaiblir le tout jeune premier ministre
Gabriel Atal fraîchement nommé le
remanement devrait intervenir je vous le
disais dans les minutes qui viennent on
va attendre le communiqué officiel de
l'Élysée pour vous donner tous les noms
bonsoir Jean-Louis bourlange bonsoir
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invité invitation vous êtes député MoDem
des haut scèes président de la
commission des affaires étrangères à
l'Assemblée nationale et j'ose le dire
député en colère agacé on peut dire ça
ce soir contre François Baayou je c'est
pas j'ai j'ai pour avec François Baayou
une relation personnelle d'amitié et de
confiance très ancienne mais je suis
effectivement assez j'ai été assez
choqué par la façon dont a été
conduit les les nég ont été conduites
les négociations pour rentrer dans le
gouvernement et la prise de position de
françoisant qu'il avait donc comme vous
l'avez rappelé un désaccord de fond
c'est dit je retiens le mot d'agacement
pour vous présenter bonsoir Carole
Bargeon merci d'être avec nous grand
reporter àop et chroniqueuse dans cette
émission bonsoir Rav de vous avoir sur
ce plateau éditorialiste politique chef
du service politique de France Inter
chroniqueur également dans sa vous
regarde et bonsoir Anne Charl Bina
bienvenue vous êtes constitutionnaliste
et politologue Jean-Dominique Merchet je
vous a des petites infos sur le
ministère des armées on en parlera sans
doute Sébastien Lecornu devrait rester
aux manettes on va d'abord planter le
décor Macron Baayou le divorce ou pas
c'est dans le recap de Bruno de qu'on
accueille tout de suite et bonsoir mon
cher Bruno bonsoir Miriam bonsoir à tous
Alors au menu de votre recécap ce soir
vous nous proposer un rambobinage mais
également une gifle oui alors
rambobinage d'abord car pour comprendre
le position
de François Baayou aujourd'hui il faut
revenir un tout petit peu en arrière ça
s'est passé lundi au terme d'une longue
procédure la justice a enfin rendu son
verdict dans l'affaire des assistants
parlementaires
européens le tribunal a dit non
seulement que je n'étais pas en cause
dans cette affaire mais qu'il n'y avait
pas de système qu'il n'y avait pas
d'enrichissement personnel le tribunal a
relaxé François beayou relaxé dans tous
les sens du terme d'ailleurs le patron
du MoDem qui attendait cette bonne
nouvelle depuis 7 ans en a profité pour
montrer qu'il était là toujours là et
qu'il était qu'il avait très envie de
revenir au cœur du Chaudron politique
est-ce que cette relaxe vous ouvre les
portes du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale que vous connaissez bien en
tout cas mais je n'écarte jamais rien le
le principe pour
moi précisément parce que vous êtes
engagé c'est de ne jamais rien écar
voilà François Baayou voulait
l'éducation nationale seulement voilà il
y a eu un os le patron du MoDem n'a pas
réussi à se mettre d'accord avec le
président de la République sur le type
de politique qu'il convenait d'y
conduire alors et ben alors il a
brusquement changé de ton et c'est donc
maintenant brenao que vous allez nous
parler d'une gifle exactement parce que
la gifle Myriam c'est un peu la
signature la petite marque personnelle
et politique de François Bayou et pour
bien comprendre il faut revenir à la
campagne présidentielle de 200 7 le jour
où à Strasbourg il s'est passé
ceci depuis cet épisode la gifle colle
littéralement à la peau du centriste
libération il a d'ailleurs fait une très
fine allusion aujourd'hui pendant que le
Figaro et le Parisien évoquaient une
crise alors pourquoi une crise et bien
précisément parce que François Baayou a
rouvert toute grande la fameuse boîte à
Gif pas content d'avoir été hconduit il
est allé coller une bonne trampe ce
matin sur France Info à Emmanuel Macron
coupable selon lui hein de mener une
politique qui conduirait la France à la
dérive il s'agit de dire
stop il y a une
dérive le moment est est venu de de
remettre les choses à l'endroit et puis
comme chez Baayou les claques se
distribuent par père et bien il a
annoncé aussitôt à mot à peine couvert
que puisque c'était comme ça il serait
candidat en 2027 et cette crise
là il faut que 2027 et les années qui
précèdent servent à montrer un chemin
pour en sortir et ces chemins c'est vous
qui allez le montrer en 2027 ben je n'ai
jamais renoncé à aucun des devoirs qui
sont les miens allons bon alors le
problème c'est Queau modem on n'a pas
l'air du tout d'accord avec la brut
du patron les 51 députés qui siègent ici
à l'Assemblée nationale ont fait
paraître cet après-midi un communiqué
dans lequel ils renouvellent leur
soutien au Premier ministre quant à vous
Jean-Louis bourlange et bien vous vous
êtes fendu d'un tweet dans lequel vous
écrivez que le comportement de François
Baayou est je vous cite politiquement
inepte et moralement dégradant bon
ambiance le comportement de Baou
modemé si elle était si si elle allit
dans
voilà enfin si j'ajoute à tout cela
myiam que cet après-midi he le parquet a
décidé de faire appel de la relax de
François baayrou vous serez probablement
d'accord avec moi pour estimer qu'on
peut se demander ce soir pour qui la
gifle est finalement la plus singlante
merci beaucoup merci Bruno Jean-Louis
bourlange on va vous écouter maintenant
en longueur on a bien compris que vous
n'avez pas goûté l'attitude de de
François Baayou pourtant vous le
connaissez très bien et de très longue
date vous allez nous dire dire ce qui
s'est passé exactement mais est-ce que
vous êtes fondamentalement surpris par
cette attitude la question la question
n'est pas de savoir si je suis surpris
contrarié agacé et et c'est même pas une
question à personnaliser je veux dire la
votre présentation très brillante a été
faite autour de la la personnalité de
François Baayou moi je crois que ce qui
est en cause c'est quelque chose de plus
objectif de plus simple aussi qui est la
le comportement que qu'on doit avoir au
sein d'une majorité moi je suis de ceux
qui pensent que il y a péril en la
demeur que la majorité est gravement
menacée sur ces deux flancs le flan de
la droite extrême de la droite profonde
et le flan de la gauche profonde je
pense qu'il y a un risque très précis
d'une rupture dans quelques années qui
se
produirait et qui menaceraiit vraiment
les fondements les fondements de
solidarité atlantique de solidarité
européenne et Fran pas conscience de ce
risque il joue il introduit au cœur de
la pour pour réussir il faut que la
majorité soit unie et je pense qu'il est
essentiel que le premier ministre
réussisse c'est pas facile il fera il va
faire des fautes il en a peut-être déjà
fait ça c'est il y a le président de la
République fait des erreurs également
mais là je crois qu'on ne peut pas
ouvrir sur je ne sais quoi parce que moi
ce que je constate c'est que François
beayrou nous informe par par
téégramation nous informe qu'il y a un
désaccord profond entre le modemme c'est
le groupe et le parti dont je suis
membre et la majorité je suis heureux de
la prendre parce que malgré tout s'il y
a un désaccord profond j'aurais pu m'en
apercevoir j'aurais pu en discuter on
aurait pu en discuter ce désaccord
profond ne sait pas sur quoi il
d'ailleurs qu' que vous considérez comme
inepte c'est-à-dire une forme de
participation sans soutien oui vous
savez la formule classique de la du
soutien sans participation par exemple
les socialistes du temps de mades France
avaient soutenu mades France sans
participé mais là on a inventé un un un
un un schéma qui me paraît complètement
étrange qui est la participation puisque
il semble bien dans le gouvernement que
dont on apprend la la composition
au personne par personne qu'il y aura
des modè mais en même temps le Président
nous dit et c'est pas un choix personnel
il nous dit que que c'est il y a une
rupture de avec de
fond donc moi je ne comprends pas
comment on peut à la fois reconnaître
une une rupture un désaccord de fond
avec la majorité pas des critiques he
des critiques c'est normal qu'on dise
qu'il faut corriger telle chose qu'il
faut mener telle politique autrement ça
c'est la vie mais un désaccord de fond
et et qu'en même temps on dit bah on a
des accords de fond bah on va y aller et
puis on va rester fidèle à la parole de
François Baayou qui nous dit qu'il y a
des accords de fond et on va rentrer
dans le
gouvernement trop intelligent pour c'est
trop intelligent pour moi je ne suis pas
c'est l' c'est l'egoo politique de
François Baayou qui pourrait peut-être
expliquer cette moi je je ne
personnalise pas je ne psychologise pas
je je fais de la politique j'ai un
engagement politique au service de la
majorité et je voudrais qu'on soit
cohérent pour vous il y a pas de
cohérence politique c'est parfaitement
clair iléisé ma n rien vu ir moi c'est
moi c'est ça qui frapp parce qu'on peut
sus disserter très longtemps sur le le
Lyon Baayou qui sort de sa cage qui sort
de son carcan judiciaire qui est relaxé
donc débridé qui va à fond mais comment
tout cela n'a pas pu être anticipé avant
sachant que Emmanuel Macron il connaît
son baayrou depuis 7 ans maintenant que
c'est l'allié historique que c'est grâce
à lui qu'il a pu devenir président
est-ce que ils nont pas pu avoir il
aurait pas pu avoir une discussion avant
le le jugement pour dire quelles sont
nos hypothèses François est-ce que
oui ou non si tu es relaxé qu'est-ce qui
se passe qu'est-ce que tu veux si tu es
pas relaxé comment on fait on a
l'impression que tout tout tout arrive
au dernier moment rien n'a été anticipé
d'ailleurs un petit peu comme ces 22
jours et demi pour solder le compte de
15 secrétaires d'État ça paraît
complètement fou quand même record sous
la 5e République il y a donc un problème
de gestion des ressources humaines qui
explique aussi ce délitement maintenant
le moment dans lequel on est est-ce que
François Baayou a lu le sondage ifope
pour valeurs actuelles ou Marine Le Pen
donné gagnante en 2027 elle n'a jamais
eu autant dans les sondages de premier
tour 36 % depuis qu'elle fait de la
politique est-ce que ça ça été intégré
est-ce que les autres Édouard Philippe
Gérald armannin demain Bruno Lemire
demain peut-être Xavier Bertrand sur le
flan de la droite sociale est-ce que
tous ces gens-là ont conscience et là je
rejoins ce que vous dites Jean-Louis
bourlange on conscience du risque de cet
espace central centre droit où la
compétition de l'après Macron démarre
prématurément et donne du grain à moudre
évidemment à l'extrême droite mais il
faut quand même essayer de mettre un mot
sur ce à quoi on a assisté est-ce que
c'est une crise est-ce que c'est un
mouvement d'humeur alors évidemment on
va voir le remanimement et si à
l'arrivée il y a beaucoup de de
ministres modemes peut-être que
politiquement il y aurait un gain à
cette attitude mais c'est un caprice
c'est un psychodrame personnel quel mot
on met sur le le coup de sang moi
j'appelle ça de François
Baayou je je ne sais pas si c'est un
caprice c'est peut-être un coup de sang
mais je sais pas si je je je ne parler
pas de caprice on a beaucoup entendu ce
terme làà depuis quelques jours mais ça
c'est un peu les éléments de langage de
de l'Élysée euh et de Matignon euh coup
de sang oui certainement parce que il
s'aperçoit qu'au fond il y a pas de
place pour lui euh Gabriel Atal ne veut
pas de lui au ministère de l'éducation
c'est tout à fait clair euh il ne veut
même sans doute pas de lui du tout dans
le gouvernement parce que on a aussi
parlé pour François Baayou à un moment
donné d'un grand ministère de la réforme
de l'État par exemple bon il voulait
l'éducation ou la cohésion des
territoires parce qu'il fustige aussi
une forme de divorce Paris provovince
maintenant là où je rejoins enfin je
suis un peu d'accord avec ce qu'a dit
Jean-Louis blange c'est que bon il ouvre
une crise dans la majorité il ouvre
aussi une crise dans son propre parti
voilà on le constate c'est assez clair
euh et c'est solitaire et c'est vrai
qu'il s'est un peu emmêlé les pinceaux
parce que honnêtement dans le communiqué
qu'il fait parvenir à la FP donc hier
soir non avanthier soir avanthier
soir non hier soir pardon so hier soir
ou oui oui euh donc il parle de des
acccords de fond à un moment donné et
puis dans un deuxième paragraphe il
parle de divergence sur la méthode et ça
ça n'a ça n'a rien à voir c'est très
différent le désaccord de fond c'est sur
la politique on peut le comprendre comme
un désaccord sur la politique générale
que mène ce gouvernement et le président
de la République alors que euh la
divergence sur la méthode on comprend
que c'est plus sur l'éducation la
manière de gérer de décision personnelle
donc ça n'engagerait que lui et euh à
cause d'une rupture de fond avec les
valeurs du mouvement donc on a un
passage permanent du personnel au
collectif qui est très troublant pour
les membres du mouvement
maintenant je suis d'accord avec ce qu'a
dit y Goos tout à l'heure c'est pas la
première fois que on a l'impression et
qu'on se demande comment ce gouvernement
ou Macron n'a pas anticipé telle crise
alors qu'il y avait des sign il y avait
des signes avant courourur et cetera et
qu'on connaitt Baayou par
cœur question que la crise arrive fait
d'accord mais je veux dire
voilà je suis donc je viens de dire
qu'il avait été assez incohérent
maintenant je vais prendre un peu sa
défense quand même
parce que voilà quelqu'un qui a quand
même
démissionné et qui a au fond fait 7 ans
de purgatoire quand même bon terrible un
purgatoire terrible injustifié et la
mesure du la la la décision d'appel du
parquet est vraiment troublante voilà
quelqu'un qui cassé dans dans sa
carrière
Poz ou c'est important quand même parce
que le parquet on l'IS en d' jeanour
qu'est-ce que vous dites troublante
parce que le parquet a décidé de faire
appel de la relaxe de François
aujourd'hui oui je trouve ça je trouve
ça très ça fait 7 ça fa 7 ans que la
justice pour des des des un problème qui
devrait se régler très simplement quel
que soit ça fait 7 ans qu'elle a mis au
frigidaire la la carrière de de de
François Baayou et que là on recommence
alors évidemment sur le plan juridique
il y a des c'est c'est une mesure assez
habituelle mais quand on voit de quoi il
s'agit je rappelle qu'il n'y a rien rien
qui mette en cause la probité la probité
du du
donc et là paf on on on on séparation
des pouvoirs oblige bon le parquet faut
le rappeler hein c'est le ministère
public la tutelle c'est le ministère de
la justice mais est-ce que vous ça vous
interroge cette coïncidence de
calendrier alors c'est important qu'on
redise quand même que voilà outre la
séparation des pouvoirs le parquet est
un organisme indépendant hein c'est
c'est c'est c'est lui qui va porter la
requête donc il y a pas si vous voulez
de de démarche d'État derrière ça c'est
c'est c'est important de de de de le
dire à l'intention de ceux qui nous
écoutent néanmoins c'est vrai que il y a
de toute façon dans notre 5e République
une une cohabitation très difficile
entre justice et politique qui ont fait
que François Baayou pour des raisons de
moralisation qu'il apporter
personnellement a donc choisi de mettre
fin à un mandat en démissionnant pour ce
motif maintenant que l'enquête est
terminée on avait le sentiment que
justement politiquement un nouvel avenir
s'offrait à lui cette cette décision de
l'appel revient à nouveau un petit peu
brouiller tout cela sur la question de
savoir si on est sur un coup de sang sur
une crise sur quelque chose de personnel
je pense que c'est un peu tout cela à la
fois mais une crise certainement parce
que ce qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est
que peut-être que cette attitude
personnelle de François Baayou vient
d'un profond dénigrement aussi de la
part d'Emmanuel Macron au moment où il
nomme Gabriel Atal de vouloir
s'affranchir en quelque sorte de sa
propre majorité c'est-à-dire que je
crois qu'il a omis qu'un gouvernement
sous la 5e République suit la coloration
de la majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
et donc au fond avoir un équilibre
gouvernemental totalement propre avec
cette idée du 15 de France dont on nous
a parlé gouvernement d'efficacité
resserré et cetera autour de ce jeune
Gabriel Atal c'était oublié aussi ses
attaches on parle souvent des éléphants
un peu de la 5e République et c'est vrai
que la place du MoDem est quand même
centrale à ce niveau-là donc il y a
peut-être un retour de manivelle à ce
point moi ce que j'aimerais dire aussi
c'est que aujourd'hui les dindons de la
farce ce sont un peu les Français qui se
retrouvent finalement face à non
seulement une deuxième composition
c'est-à-dire une suite de gouvernement
mais à un remaniement puisqu'on apprend
qu'une des ministres perd son poste et
un rem qui en fait n'emporte même pas le
nom on a eu un Premier ministre qui
s'est engagé auprès de l'Assemblée
nationale à présenter son programme sans
avoir son gouvernement dans son
intégralité donc on est vraiment dans un
système institutionnel qui n'a plus
vraiment de sens on a fait passer la
communication avant la politique et
avant même le sens de la
continuité la fonction publique depuis
plus d'un mois alors jel B je voulez
intervenir il juste aprèsoui moi je suis
entièrement d'accord avec ce que vous
dites sur le fait que le le gouvernement
tel qu'il a été constitué dans sa
première partie était tout à fait
déséquilibré au détriment du MoDem je
l'ai dit il y avait un ministre issu de
mem qui est monsieur fenau le ministre
de l'Agriculture et huit ministres qui à
titre ou un autre euh étit issu de LR à
un moment ou un autre je ne je trouve ça
très bien
d'êtreire c'est tout à fait bon et là
j'ai dit à ce moment-là j'ai dit
clairement j'ai fait des publications en
disant le compte n'y est pas le compte n
est pas mais et et j'ai j'ai suggéré
qu'on pouvait faire un soutien sans
participation si on veut pas de nous à
une juste place dans le gouvernement bah
on soutient sans participation mais là
où la chose a été différente et ce qui
m'a choqué hier c'est que on a fait
porter le désaccord sur les valeurs et
les valeurs sur le fondement sur les
orientations politiques profondes et là
je demande à voir si on a un désaccord
je voudrais savoir sur quoi que c'est
sur la politique européenne la politique
est que c'est sur la méthode parce que
c'est vrai que sur le D
je suis entièrement d'accord aussi avec
le fait que cette affaire a été conduite
par le président de la République de
façon assez étrange et notamment ce
gouvernement en deux morceaux quel
choseou n'est pas l'unique responsable
le président l' ai je continue sur mes
DRH qui ont fait des la mauvaise gestion
des ressources humaines récemment Atal
et Macron est-ce qu'ils connaissent leur
histoire politique est-ce qu'ils ont lu
François Baayou en 2009 d'un son panflet
abus de pouvoir très violent très
virulent contre Nicolas Sarkozi 100000
exemplaires je crois si on ne connaît
pas François Baayou si on ne connaît pas
son allergie viscérale à Sarkozi est-ce
qu'il a représenté au sarkoosisme et
qu'est-ce qui porte la marque du nouveau
gouvernement du 15 de France départ là
c'est évidemment le néosarcosisme à la
fois dans le positionnement dans les
mots dans le choix de Catherine vauterin
dans le retour de Rachid hadti ça ne pas
avoir anticipé que ça pourrait fortement
irrité François Baayou et plus largement
le modem c'est méconnaître ses alliés
politiques et ne pas respecter sa
majorité question la question est quand
même pardon pardon parce que moi je me
pose la même question c'est-à-dire vous
Myriam vous disaz à quoi joue Baayou moi
j'aurais je voudrais dire aussi à qu bon
et euh de ce point de vue-là est-ce
qu'on peut tout à fait exclure que au
fond Emmanuel Macron qui est
certainement extrêmement reconnaissant à
François baayrou de l'avoir appelé à
faire ce pacte en 2017 qui lui a permis
de regagner les points qu'il avait un
peu perdu et cetera et donc qui bon qui
a contribué à sa victoire euh on sait
très bien qu'Emmanuel Macron n'aime pas
beaucoup de voir quoi que ce soit à
quiconque donc est-ce qu'on peut tout à
fait exclure qu'au fond euh et on a bien
vu que au fil des années euh François
baayrou pas seulement à cause de sa
condamnation et du fait que enfin pardon
de l'instruction qui était en cours euh
et qu'il était un un peu sur le côté
mais on a senti quand même qu'il était
marginalisé qu'il agçait et cetera donc
est-ce qu'au fond euh Atal et Macron ne
sont pas Sié contents d'être débarrassé
de quelqu'un dont on tout le monde dit
qu'il est un poids lourd et considère un
peu comme un dinosaur nombre de
ministres mais c'est clair que
politiquement on sent que il largue les
amars peut-être dans dans le but aussi
de de pouvoir battre faire battre Marine
Le Pen avec avec le successeur de c'est
Macron dans la dans la la prise de
décision c'est quand même alors
jeandominique Merchet peut-être vous
vouliez intervenir euh peut-être quand
même sur les les justifications de de
François baayrou qui refuse le ministère
des armées il y a bien un ministère
régalien c'est celui-là mais en disant
après tout c'est le seul qui marche donc
on a pas besoin de moi je veux être
utile ça c'est une histoire un peu
parallèle à à l'histoire principale dont
on vient de parler oui il il a été
proposé hier à François baayrou de
prendre à défaut des ministères qu'il
souhaitait c'est-à-dire l'éducation et
l'aménagement du territoire on lui dit
bah finalement si tu veux prends les
armées alors ça c'est très très mal
passé dans la communauté de défense en
général et je pense chez Sébastien lecnu
aussi ça veut dire quoi ça ça veut dire
que quand même on oublie un petit détail
il y a une guerre en Europe il y a une
guerre à Gaza on tous les jours le
président dit leur armement le machin il
on dit bon mais c'est pas grave pour un
poste aussi capital que le ministre des
armées on dit ça peut être un lot de
consolation alors même que tout le monde
sait de droite à gauche et au centre
encore plus je pense que Sébastien le
Cornu est réellement un bon ministre il
fait le boulot je n'entends pas de
critique contre Sébastien lecnu et donc
donc c'est lui faire une mauvaise
manière que d'envoyer le publiquement le
signal qu' éta r lui il veut rester au
ministère des des armées il fait du bon
boulot et on lui dit bon mais c'est pas
grave tu vas céder ta place pour euh
pour ne pas fâcher euh euh Baayou Baayou
a eu le la je pense l'élégance de le
refuser et et d'expliquer pourquoi en
disant justement bah non c'est un
ministère qui marche en plus il n'y
connaît rien la défense euh voilà c'est
un c'est intéressant ce problème de la
défense car je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est un ministère absolument central
dans la conjoncture actuelle non
seulement avec la la question de de
immédiate de la guerre de
h comme ça le problème de l'avenir de
l'EM du système de défense français et
européens dans la perspective de
changement de président aux États-Unis
c'est un problème vital simplement je
crois que effectivement François Baou
sait que dans ces domaines là tout est
verrouillé par le président de la
répuiqueement un faire valoir et ça il
n'a pas une il n'a pas une ambition de
faire valoir à re faire la loi et je
crois que là il a raison alors il est
20h moin 3 minutes on a toujours pas le
communiqué officiel on vous dira quand
même les noms qui reviennent avec avec
quasi certitude dans dans un tout petit
instant mais les conséquences à
l'Assemblée les conséquences au sein des
50 députés modem parce que quand même
quand je regarde le communiqué du MoDem
il est plus clément que le vôtre hein
quand même alors certes il est tout à
fait Clément ils acceptent volontiers de
participer moi je je pose un problème je
dis est-ce qu'on peut qu au fond la
majorité et faire partie du gouvernement
mes collègues apparemment trouvent que
c'est il rappelle la justice sociale la
solidarité territoriale la transition
écologique comme étant les fondamentaux
du MoDem l'humanisme du MoDem sa fibre
social ça veut dire que ils vont se
sentir quoi autorisés à voter contre ou
s'abstenir texte par texte davantage je
pense que en fait ce qu'il faut retenir
de cet épisode c'est justement pas
tellement la grogne de François Baayou
mais la conséquence que ça implique sur
la vie parlementaire qui est déjà très
fracturée au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale et au sein du Sénat il faut
savoir aujourd'hui que les oppositions
s'ans sont donné à cœur joie sur le fait
qu'on était en fin de règne que
précisément ça serait difficile de
gouverner et c'est la vérité les
coalitions s'apportent pas trop au
bonheur hein sous la 5e République et
nous avons une majorité de coalition des
oppositions de coalition donc ça va être
très difficile de savoir comment on va
gouverner j'ajoute que je vous rejoins
là-dessus on on quitte finalement ce
communiqué avec le sentiment que une
fracture française existe entre les
représentants et les représentés ce sont
les termes qu'a utilisé François Baayou
et qu'on ne sait pas si précisément les
nouveaux ministres entrant si les
députés vont être en charge ou non de la
résorber cette fracture est-ce que cette
question a juste été dégainé à ce
moment-là pour expliquer un désaccord
personnel ou est-ce que à l'avenir à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est des
questions qui seront posées par ces
députés modem est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on
va vraiment avoir une solution à tout ça
est-ce que c'est
pas disent non c'est la dissolution
précipitée ah oui mais les 50 ne diront
pas non
ser sur quoi ça va marcher sous ça à
condition que le Parlement et que
l'assemblée est encore une utilité dans
les 6 mois qui viennent parce que il y a
une pause clairement qui est mise sur
l'activité parlementaire sur les grands
textes rien de très intéressant de très
fort avant le 9 juin date des élections
européennes pas de vague pas de 493 si
possible pas de motion de censure voilà
donc le problème des 5 prochains mois
c'est comment gérer l' nuit aussi sur
les bandes de l'Assemblée hein alors on
y vient sur sur les noms vous l'avez
compris le communiqué n'est toujours pas
officiel il n'est pas tombé il devrait
intervenir dans les minutes qui viennent
mais il y a quand même un certain nombre
voilà de de quasi certitude ce soir
Amélie oua Castera quitterait
l'éducation nationale mais garderait le
sport elle serait remplacée rue de
Grenelle par Nicole Boubet autre entrant
Frédéric Valtou ministre délégué à la
santé sous l'autorité de Catherine au
train c'est un député horizon proche de
Édouard Philippe ages panier runachi
deviendrait ministre des Solidarités
après avoir été au commande de la
transition énergétique Guillaume
casbarian député Renaissance prendrait
le portefeuille du logement Marie
gevennou arriverait aux outrem et le
député la députée modem Marina Ferrari
prendrait en charge les affaires
européennes Sabrina Agresti roubache
maintenu à la ville à la citoyenneté et
à l' héritrait en plus de l'intégration
Dominique fort du par radical serait
maintenu à la ruralité aux collectivités
territoriales olivire Grégoire reste au
gouvernement en charge des entreprises
du tourisme et de la consommation et
Sarah al aie ministre modem en charge de
l'enfance et des familles jeannoël Barou
vous l'avez pour l'instant on n pas le
nom ça vous inquiète ça c'est un ami
très très grande action dans le domaine
du numérique et vraiment c'est c'est
quelqu'un dont je je crois que la
carrière allez le plus important c'est
Amélie Ouda casterra ça c'est une quasi
certitude elle quitte elle quitte
l'éducation nationale c'était le le seul
absè de fixation à crever dans ce
gouvernement puisque il y avait vraiment
là une là aussi DRH Macron DRH Atal
laissit pourrir une situation pendant 10
jours 15 jours avec un supplice
quotidien d'une ministre qui n'est pas
du tout adoubée par les personnels
d'éducation nationale qui vont
travailler avec elle comment ça pouvait
continuer ça ne pouvait pas continuer
mais le supplice aura D et Nicole Boubet
vous qui suivez les questions
d'éducation une ancienne rectrice
ancienne ministre de la Justice femme de
gauche elle a été militante au Parti
socialiste elle sera la femme de la
situation avec les syndicat oui enfin
c'est quand même un peu étrange
franchement pardon
euh sans mettre du tout en question les
qualités de Madame Boubet mais elle
avait pris des position il y a quelques
années contre l'uniforme notamment
contre l'uniforme elle avait traité de
faribol faribol toutes ces histoires de
rétablissement de l'autorité bon enfin
c'est absolument exactement le contraire
de tout ce qu'a annoncé Gabriel hatal et
qui au passage était quand même
plébicité par les
Français toutes ces
mesures non non mais c'est complètement
donc là moi je dois dire je tombe de mon
armoire pardon ouais Valtou Frédéric
Valtou à la santé l'ancien président de
la Fédération des hôpitaux de France moi
je vais pas commenter les les personnes
ce que je constate pour pour Madame
mouea c'est que au bout du compte elle
perd la tête elle garde les
jambes c'est quand même voilà il est àun
ce soir jeanl bourlange unice on dit qui
a duré et surtout pour cette solution là
pour arriver à ce que finalement au bout
de 22 jours on la démette de sa fonction
est-ce que c'était vraiment utile de de
de faire continuer cela et est-ce que
finalement l'idée de retronquer ce
ministère en deux prouve pas finalement
que on a un petit peu joué avec nos
administrations comme des appellations
et et ça je crois que c'est un petit peu
dangereux de faire de la politique
spectacle avec nos nos plus grands
ministères cette idée d'avoir des
ministres un peu partout avec des
ministres délégués qui sont plein
potentièes ou pas ça va être quand même
un vrai cassettegation pour termin ça
donne quand même vraiment l'impression
de du n'importe quoi allez B termin je
crois aussi du n'importe quoi du
n'importe quoi pour je croiscoutez c'est
c'est c'est le citoyen qui parle là le
modem effectivement c'est le modem va
être présent euh alors qu'on dit qu' en
a un désaccord l'éducation nationale on
change du tout au tout ça fait quand
même le 3ème changement à vu on a vu on
a eu blancire le contraire de blancire
le contraire du contraire de blancire et
maintenant le le contraire du contraire
du contraire de blan ça révèle je trouve
pardon c'est vrai que je suis un peu
passionnée par les questions de l'école
ce que je trouve qui est très révélateur
c'est qu'on a autant de mal à trouver
quelqu'un pour occuper le B touche bien
la fonction qui est celle en principe de
la merde de toutes les batailles comme
voilà pour un deuxème quinena qui devait
être relancé en à peine commencer merci
beaucoup on s'arrête là on va regarder
de près ce communiqué on reviendra
demain bien sûr sur les équilibres
politiques et même géographiqu cher à
François Baayou merci à vous merci
d'être venu débattre sur LCP vous restez
avec moi Jean-Dominique mer dans une
dizaine de minutes Vincent HUG va
revenir sur la crise politique au
Sénégal Pierre-Henri tavoyot sur la
votation parisienne sur les SUV gare au
gadget Démocr pratique et puis quel est
le menu de Bourbon Express ce soir
Stéphanie des piierres l'agenda de
l'Assemblée nationale qui reste
désespérément vide à tout à l'heure les
affranchis pour vos parties prix mais
d'abord sommes-nous prêts pour la guerre
c'est la question un peu amboissante
hein j'ose le dire de votre dernier
livre Jean-Dominique Merchet à vous lire
nos armées pourtant performantes et bien
ne tiendrait pas un front de plus de 80
km en cas d'opération majre c'est même
pas Paris chartre pour se figurer les
les choses alors comment en sommes-nous
arriv là élément de réponse dans
l'invitation de ma Frémont interview
juste
après si on vous invite Jean-Dominique
merché c'est parce que le monde
s'embrase à Gaza et en Ukraine pour la
première fois depuis plusieurs décennies
l'Europe est confrontée à ses portes à
une guerre de haute intensité face à la
Russie de Vladimir Poutine l'Occident
vit un tournant historique la fin de son
hégémonie ce qui oblige les pays
européens à revoir et à moderniser leurs
industries militaire alors qu'en est-il
de notre pays la France est-elle encore
une puissance mondiale sommes-nous
Jean-Dominique mercher prêt pour la
guerre c'est d'ailleurs le titre de
votre dernier ouvrage on a une petite
armée qui permet de faire plein de
choses différentes plutôt bien parce que
c'est une armée réellement
professionnelle
mais pas beaucoup et pas longtemps or ce
qu'on voit ressurgir c'est la nécessité
d'être en masse et d'être en masse
longtemps Jean-Dominique mercher vous
êtes journaliste à l'opinion expert des
questions militaires et stratégiques
auteur de nombreux ouvrages voici donc
votre dernier livre 216 pages pour
dresser un état des lieux alarmant de
notre défense pour vous la France vit
dans l'illusion de son statut de grande
puissance face aux nouvelles menaces que
vaut notre armée dotée de l'arsenal
nucléaire et membre de l'OTAN elle est
à la ramasse en dépit des moyens
considérables mis sur la table nos
militaires se battent au péril de leur
vie pour défendre notre pays et notre
République et dans le cadre de la loi de
programmation militaire nous tiendrons
nos engagements vis-à-vis d'eux en deux
quinenas nous aurons doublé le budget du
ministère de la
Défense une petite armée dites-vous une
armée bonzaï incapable de tenir 80 km de
front terrestre mais qui peut se déplo y
dans tous les domaines n'est-ce pas là
finalement Jean-Dominique merch notre
véritable force voilà une armée
polyvalente petite mais est-ce qu'elle
est costaud au moins dans son domaine
dans ses différents domaines oui elle
est on a une bonne armée il y a aucun
doute là armée professionnelle les gars
quand ils font des choses ils les font
bien c'est donc pas une critique du
fonctionnement de de l'armée c'est une
critique du modèle le modèle il est
un modèle de vouloir faire comme les
américains c'est-à-dire d'être présent
partout dans tous les domaines dans sur
dans du Pacifique à l'Afrique de
l'Europe à l'Amérique latine de de
l'espace des forces spéciales le cyber
le nucléaire les porortes-avions les
chats d'avoir une armée complète donc on
est aussi performant mais beaucoup plus
petit c'est ça nous ne sommes pas les
États-Unis et qui plus est nous avons
3000 milliards d'endettement et donc
nous avons ce que j'ai appelé une armée
bon c'est-à-dire c'est l'armée
américaine en tout petit alors ça a des
avantages ça permet effectivement de
faire des choses les faire bien aller
chercher des ressortissant au Soudan
comme l'année dernière de participer à
des clubs comme aim a dit aiment le dire
les militaires on fait partie du club
des puissance nucléire du club des
puissances aéronavales du club des
puissances spatiales mais dès lors qu'on
rentre dans le vif du sujet ce qui
frappe le grand public justement
évidemment dès lors qu'on rentre dans le
vif du sujet là on ne fait pas on fait
les choses on les fait pas beaucoup et
on les fait pas longtemps parce qu'on n
pas la masse et l'épaisseur alors c'est
80 km je rappelle que le front éprien
c'est 1000 km c'est pas un chiffre
secret mais c'est pas un chiffre qui
aurait dû sortir au fond ça fait pas
plaisir aux officiels d'abord d'où vient
précisément ce chiffre alors ça vient je
suis invité à un collocque comme il y a
des centaines enfin des dizaines de
collocques tous les organisés par les
militaires et là on nous présente les
capacités de l'armée ceci cela machin et
à un moment il y a un officier qui dit
voilà bah nous notre capacité de
déploiement c'est 25000 hommes et puis
le modèle le modèle de l'otence qui est
le nôtre c'est TS d'hommes par kilomètre
des brigades déployé et donc je je je je
fais simplement le calcul je dis 25000
hommes c'est 80 km donc d oui oui c'est
ça c'est ce qu'on pourrait tenir dans le
cadre d'une opération majeure de l'OTAN
pour bien comprendre 25000 hommes c'est
la capacité maximale des soldats
opérationnels au sol de projection de
l'armée française en cas d'attaque alors
guerre dans le temps peu mais c'est peu
pourtant on a beaucoup plus de soldats
que ça rle oui mais parce que les alors
comment vous expliquez ça les autres
sont ailleurs voilà les autres on a une
armée en gros 200 250000 hommes mais
vous avez l'aviation les vous avez des
gens qui sont dans le Pacifique vous
avez des gens qui sont en Afrique vous
avez des gens qui sont dans dans dans
différents services et puis vous avez
des gens qui sont dans l'armée de l'air
dans la marine et donc pour la guerre à
l'Ukrainienne l'ucrainienne nous mettons
dans l'alliance c'est ça c'est
parfaitement clair alors cette cette
armée échantillonnaire cette armée
bonaille elle coûte en plus très très
cher c'est ça qui est aussi le le
paradoxe de nos choix les satellites le
cyber les sous-marins ça pèse très lourd
en fait vous nous dites qu'on on n' pas
su faire suffisamment de choix on n' pas
concentré nos efforts budgétaires
suffisamment sur quoi précisément
pourtant les budgets sont là ils ont
doublé alors ça ce c'est un choix
politique dont il faut débattre est-ce
qu'il faut continuer à éparpiller les
choses comme on le fait dans tous les
domaines euh ça ça coûte de plus en plus
cher parce que il y a de plus en plus de
domaines il y a le spatial il y a le
cyber il y a maintenant les fonds
sous-marins avec par exemple l'attaque
de Nordstream on a vu ce que ça
signifiait et puis dans toute la
géographie c'estàdire est qu'il faut
rester présent dans le pacifique sous
prétexte que nous avons trois îles et et
et deux archipels et cetera et cetera
donc il faut se poser les questions où
est-ce qu'on fait ce que le maréchal
Foch le vainqueur de la première guerre
mondiale conseiller de faire dans ces
traités sur l'art de la guerre qui était
de dire il faut concentrer ces moyens
l'art de la guerre c'est de concentrer
ses moyens alors Sébastien lecorneu avec
qui vous avez forcément un dialogue sur
ces sujets pourrait vous dire mais
attendez euh l'attaque à la russe
n'arrivera jamais chez nous on a une
dissuasion nucléaire on est dans l'OTAN
on a aussi des avions de chasse qui à la
minute où on serait attaqué irait
bombarder l'ennemi euh et donc
l'hypothèse même oui d'une guerre au sol
n'existe pas c'est mon premier chapitre
je pose le premier chapitre je dis
est-ce qu'on doit se préparer à une
guerre comme en Ukraine la réponse est
non nous ne serons pas nous ne sommes
pas l'Ukraine pour ces raisons-là parce
que nous avons l'arme nucléaire parce
que nous avons le parce que nous sommes
memb de l'Alliance atlantique mais on
voit bien que la situation de l'Europe a
profondément changé depuis l'année
dernière enfin depuis 2022 avec
l'attaque russe et que ça ça va durer et
que si on s'inscrit comme le fait le
président de la République dans un
projet d'Union européenne de d'union de
plus en plus étroite toujours plus
étroite des Européens qui est ma
conviction personnelle là il faut se
concentrer sur ce nouvel ordre du de
l'Europe et ce nouvel ordre de l'Europe
ce qui s'est passé avec l'invasion de
l'Ukraine c'est aussi important que la
chute du mur de Berlin donc il faut
qu'on soit proche de nos amis et de nos
alliés alors justement et là on on est
on est allié mais ça tarde à venir et
c'est peut-être d'ailleurs à cause de ça
euh l'absence de de livraison d'armes en
quantité suffisante que les Ukrainiens
peuvent je dis bien c'est une hypothèse
perdre cette guerre gros problème de
stock révélé par la guerre en Ukraine
nos canons César nos charlecler ont
tardit à être livré parce qu'on en a pas
assez quand on pense à la à la défense
on pense à l'armée mais en fait on
oublie l'autre élément qui est aussi
essentiel qui est l'industrie de défense
une défense ça repose sur des militaires
une armée mais ça repose aussi sur des
capacités de production et des capacités
technologiques et effectivement nous
n'avons pas et c'est certainement
aujourd'hui le plus gros problème que
nous avons que que nous nous avons à
supporter c'est nous n'avons pas la
capacité de remonter en puissance de
cette industrie malgré on va dire le
retour de la souverainé Industri
imaginez que pour fabriquer un missile
antiaérien comparable au patriotes par
exemple
euh l'aster il faut au moins 3 ans au
moins 3 ans entre le moment où vous
dites je l'achète et le moment où il
vous a livré même chose pour un avion
rafale alors là vous parlez de nos
fleurons technologiques mais même pour
les munitions mais même pour les m on
s'est rendu compte qu'il fallait les
munitions puisque pour les munitions il
n'y a plus d'industrie en France de la
munition donc elle ça tout ça a été
démantelé dans le cadre de la
désindustrialisation du pays qui a
touché moins la défense que d'autres
secteurs mais qui a quand même touché la
défense on sait par exemple qu'on ne
produit plus de de fusil d'assaut
français c'est la première fois depuis
Louis XIV c'est peut-être pas grave les
Allemands font de très bon mais il faut
s'entendre alors si on achète des choses
aux Allemands il faut que les Allemands
en comp en compensation nous s'achè des
choses l'erreur stratégique depuis
l'Ukraine c'est de pas avoir les
capacités de monter en puissance on l'a
bien compris sur l'Ukraine aujourd'hui
euh est-ce que vous avez l'impression
qu'Emmanuel Macron euh qui s'est engagé
hein dans la raison d'armes importantes
on est passé des chars aux avions et et
à chaque fois on monte davantage mais
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que il
a pris conscience de l'enjeu que que si
l'Ukraine perdait cette guerre c'est
toute l'Europe qui serait affaiblie
alors je pense qu'il est toujours dans
une forme d'hésitation non pas sur le
fait que euh la Russie ne doit pas
gagner la guerre euh il le dit mais il
ne dit jamais la Russie doit perdre la
guerre c'est la pourtant c'est de ça
dont il s'agit il faut que la Russie
perde cette guerre c'est la sécurité du
continent européen qui est en jeu si la
Russie ne perd pas cette guerre c'est si
elle n'a pas l'impression de perdre
cette guerre si elle dit pas un jour bon
c'est bon c'est au-dessus de mes moyens
il faut que j'arrête nous nous emprenons
pour des années et des années peut-être
30 40 ans 50 ans comme pour la guerre
froide donc il est c'est pas la question
des Ukrainiens c'est notre c'est notre
guerre guerre à tous mais mais quel est
votre sentiment sur l'avenir alors on
s'ê àit mon sentiment estiste que que ce
qu'on entend généralement je pense que
les Ukrainiens le le sur le le front
terrestre est bloqué depuis plus d'un an
avancé ici ou là recul bon les
Ukrainiens ont échoué ont raté leur
offensif d'été bon c'est évident mais
ils sont en train de marquer des points
très importants dans dans dans une
campagne stratégique et notamment ils
reprennent peu à peu le contrôle de la
mer Noire et il et il rendent de plus en
plus inv
la situation des Russ en Crimé grâce au
livraisons NOTAM des euré grâce aux
livraisons donc il faut qu'elle se
poursuive donc ils n'ont pas du tout
perdu la guerre merci beaucoup merci
Jean-Dominique merch sommes-nous prêts
pour la guerre réponse largement en
demi-teinte mais qui ouvre un débat
public dont les citoyens doivent
s'emparer parce que c'est c'est nous
c'est c'est notre
armée c'est nous peut-être nos vies
aussi merci beaucoup c'estchz Robert
Lafond vous restez avec moi c'est
l'heure d'accueillir nos affranchis leur
parti prix vont vous faire réagir on les
accueille tout de suite
le grand reporter Vincent eugu qui nous
parle de la situation au Sénégal ce soir
Pierre-Henri tavoyot pour la philosophie
bienvenue à tous les deux installez-vous
on commence comme chaque soir par
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée c'est Stéphanie Despierre
qui nous la raconte ce soir bonsoir
Stéphanie bonsoir et ce soir je vous
raconte l'histoire d'une assemblée au
chômage technique après une année 2023
avec un hémicycle en surchauff des
semaines à rallonge des séances la nuit
le weekend et bien l'ordre du jour s'est
subitement vidé depuis début janvier et
l'ennuie guette est-ce qu'on s'ennuie
quand on est député alors non on
s'ennuie pas parce que moi je prépare ma
proposition de lois sur les pénuries
pour lutter contre les pénuries de
médicaments donc je fais une quinzaine
d'auditions mais il est vrai que
l'agenda de l'Assemblée nationale est
assez léger en ce moment on est jeudi la
prochaine séance n'aura lieu que mardi
alors le jeudi n'est pas la journée la
plus chargée car les députés sont sur le
terrain mais là le Palais Bourbon est
quasiment désert les couloirs bien
silencieux et soyons franc pas été
facile de trouver des députés à porter
de micro l'interminable remanement
plusieurs épisodes gèlent le travail
parlementaire pas de texte majeur pas de
grande réforme l'agenda des députés est
presque vide cette semaine l'assemblée
n'a siégé que mardi et mercredi seul
deux textes ont été examinés et la
semaine prochaine et bien ce sera le
même tarif alors les députés ont
carrément le blues en toute franchise
vous avez l'impression que vous servez
encore à quelque chose j'ose encore
l'espérer mais je vais pas vous mentir
parfois je me pose la question aussi
c'est clair la majorité relative avait
redonné de l'enjeu au débat dans
l'hémicycle mais comme beaucoup de
textes sont adoptés par 493 et bien
quand on est député de l'opposition
comme Valérie Rabo c'est encore plus
difficile de faire entendre sa voix
surtout quand l'Assemblée ne siège pas
et ça ne devrait pas s'arranger puisque
lors d'un conseil des ministres
mi-janvier le président de la République
a dit qu'il voulait moins de lois
forcément dans les couloirs on
s'inquiète voire on s'agace le vrai
sujet c'est que quand on ne passe pas
par l'Assemblée nationale
on ne passe pas par ceux qui
représentent le peuple pour faire la loi
c'est ça le fond du sujet et en effet je
pense que c'est une situation grave à
laquelle on est en train de s'habituer
un court circuitage continu de ceux qui
font la loi et donc on va faire comment
des aspects réglementaires des décisions
ministérielles une espèce de
divertissement permanent c'est ici que
les choses doivent se faire non pas pour
occuper les députés mais parce que les
seuls représentants du peuple dans une
démocratie parlementaire ce sont les
députés bon elle devrait s'arrêter vite
cette période de flottement non avec
cette cette nouvelle équipe Quiou on a
la nouvelle équipe qui se met en place
donc ça devrait s'améliorer les affaires
parlementaires devraient reprendre un
peu en mars il y aura un congrès à
versaill pour inscrire le droit à l'IVG
dans la Constitution une nouvelle loi
agricole est aussi en préparation pour
fin février une sur la fin de vie avant
l'été mais le calendrier reste encore
très flou alors on en saura peut-être un
peu plus dans les prochains jours oui il
séminire gouvernemental he qui devrait
fixer la fameuse feuille de route dans
les dans les prochains jours merci
beaucoup Stéphanie Tiane que bonbon
express pour le coup ou elle est bonne
ou c'est stupéfiant d'un mot moi je suis
stupéfait j'imagine ce qui se dit dans
les les gens qui entendent ça dans dans
les bistr et pas que dans les bistr dans
les dans les beaux salons aussi en
disant tiens on tiens les députés et
loin de moi de faire de
l'antiarlementarisme surtout sur cette
chaîne euh mais vient on vient de
comprendre les députés si tu accordé 300
€ d'augmentation et on nous explique qu'
font qu' travaillent de moins en moins
mais mais pour les Français nourir le
populisme simplement impossible faute de
texte he il faut bien le préciser du
gouvernement c'est le gouvernement qui
mais c'est quand même assez incroyable
allez euh on enchaîne on enchaîne avec
qui qui veut commencer normalement c'est
Pierre-Henri allez Pierre-Henri on me
dit Pierre-Henri dans l'oreillette vous
vouliez revenir sur les SUV la votation
de Annie dalgo et et vous nous nous
avertissez attention he attention au
gadgets démocratiques oui il faut
rappeler les les résultats donc
54,55 % on répondu à cette question vous
voulez-vous un tarif spécifique pour le
stationnement des voitures individuelles
lourd encombrante et polluante bon et
une partie anticipation de moins de 6 %
donc en effet est-ce que c'est vraiment
une réussite on peut en douter ce genre
de consultation a trois objectifs en
général il faut créer un débat il faut
arriver à organiser si sinon un
consensus du moins une majorité et puis
aider à la décision c'est ça qui est
important ça permet de favoriser la
décision de ce point de vue-l les trois
objectifs ne sont pas du tout atteints
il y a pas eu de débat parce que la
question était d'ailleurs très partiale
il y a pas eu non plus de consensus
puisque quand on regarde les les
arrondissements les résultats sont
complètement éclatés des argement très
pour et très contre et puis il y a pas
du tout d'aide à la décision parce que
si le conseil municipal suit la
consultation lui dira bah vous avez eu
la participation s'il ne suit pas on
dira bah vous avez trahi l'expression
des Français donc franchement c'est un
truc qui sert à rien ah oui inutile donc
l'exer inutile et je vais même plus loin
c'est nocif c'est nociif parce que on on
a c'est une insulte faite à la
l'impartialité des délibérations et même
à la responsabilité politique je pas
favorable à cette décision mais le maire
de Lyon lui a pris la décision
d'augmenter le stationnement il s'est
dit voilà je c'est ma responsabilité
j'ai pas besoin de consulter et puis si
je suis pas si les Lyonnais sont pas
d'accord iront la prochaine fois voilà
mais de façon plus générale je pense que
ça pose vraiment le problème de cette
démocratie participative dont on fait un
peu la panacée avec notre crise de la
démocratie représentative et c'est vrai
que c'est quand même une appellation
très très peu contrôlée cette démocratie
participative au fond participation de
qui et à quoi de qui faut bien
reconnaître qu'en général c'est les gens
qui ont un peu le temps qui ont rien
d'autre à faire ou alors les militant ou
les lobby en tout genre donc c'est une
usurpation du peuple souvent par
ailleurs à quoi la démocratie il y a
plusieurs moments il y a le moment des
élections il y a le moment de la
délibération il y a le moment de la
décision il y a le moment de la rédition
de comptes bah oui il faut dire à quoi
ça sert de ce point de vuelà les budgets
participatif franchement l'expérience
des budgets participatifs dans la
plupart du temps ce sont pas mal
d'argent public qui est confié au vote
d'une poignée de bobo qui vont choisir
des projets innovants et créatifs mais
franchement ça frise la démagogie alors
est-ce que l'idée de démocratie
participative est illusoire je pense pas
on peut la défendre mais il faut
vraiment là-dessus être très rigoureux
un euh il faut qu'elle complète la
démocratie représentative et non pas
qu'elle la remplace ou même la
concurrence parce que sinon ça crée un
choc de représentation très grave
deuxièmement il faut qu'on lui
garantisse vraiment l'impartialité
contre l'entrisme militant troisièmement
il faut qu'on en use sans en abuser
rarement sinon ça sert à rien et puis
enfin l'objectif principal au fond je
crois je crois que c'est vraiment un
objectif de convivialité il faut grâce à
cette démocratie représentative mettre
de la convivialité dans la démocratie
locale qui autrement n'en a pas et sinon
effectivement la démocratie
participative ça sera une dictature d'un
nouveau genre la dictature de ceux qui
ont le temps oui ou des militants et
d'ailleurs quand on voit les taux de
participation c'est dit j'aime bien
l'idée de la convivialité dans la
démocratie participative merci beaucoup
je vous vais vous faire réagir je garde
un peu de temps pour Vincent eug parce
qu'elle est un peu pour vous cette ce
soir Vincent voulait revenir sur la
situation au Sénégal bien le Sénégal se
prévut à bon droit de sa longue
tradition pluraliste et de ses
alternances plus ou moins apaisé au
point de revendiquer le statut
d'exception vertueuse dans l'espace
subsaharien autant dire que les
convulsions qui secouent le pays de la
Teranga l'hospitalité en wolof ont de
quoi troubler c'est le 3 février que
l'orage éclate dans le ciel de Dakar un
ciel obscurci depuis 2 ans par de lourds
nuages ce jour-là le chef de l'État
mackyall annonce avoir abrogé le décret
de convocation du corps électoral pour
le 25 de ce mois date du premier tour de
la présidentielle motif invoqué le
conflit survenu quant au processus de
validation des candidatures entre
l'Assemblée nationale et le Conseil
constitutionnel conseil dont l'un des
prétendants recalés l'opposant Karim wad
exilé au Qatar depuis 2016 accuse deux
des juges d'avoir été corrompus les
députés de son parti adoptent alors avec
l'appui décisif de leurs collègues de la
majorité une résolution créant une
commission d'enquête parlementaire d'où
la nécessité invoquée par Macky Sall de
tout remettre à plat l'épisode suivant
de ce thriller date de lundi soir au
terme d'une séance électrique
l'Assemblée vote à la cravache une loi
visant à différer le scrutin de 10 mois
donc à proroger d'autant et au mépris du
droit le mandat du sortant on a quand
même vu à cette occasion une escette de
gendarmes casqué expulser manu militar
de l'hémicycle les élus qui s'échinaient
à enrayer la manœuvre manœuvre
c'est-à-dire c'est un coup de théâtre
qui qui résulte d'un calcul politique
c'est en tout cas rudement bien imité
car la bataille prédendument juridique
masquemal impacte en apparence contre
nature celui scellé par le clan
présidentiel et l'ennemi juré d'hier à
savoir le fils de l'ancien président
abdouah wad disons-le tout net c'est à
contrecœur que makcky a renoncé l'été
dernier à briguer un troisème bail c'est
à reculon qu'il a intronisé en septembre
dans le rôle de l'héritier son premier
ministre amadouba lequel est en but
depuis lors au travail de SAP de Rivau
dépité pront à lui savonner la planche
il faut dire que la campagne du dauphin
par défaut peine à décoller au point que
mon doute au sein de la coalition
présidentielle profondément divisée de
sa capacité à terrasser le candidat du
pastef une formation souverainiste
radical un candidat qui ne risque pas
d'enchaîner au demeurant les meetings il
est en prison tout comme son leader
Ousman Sonko à la veille du dénouement
de la Coupe d'Afrique des Nations de
football la tentation d'étirer le temps
additionnel du kakena finissant a donc
emporté et les réactions alors au
sénégalais ailleurs bah disons qu'il y a
du carton jaune dans l'air pour le coup
la société civile locale s'insurge les
dersr religieux aussi ton juge le report
de l'échéance illégitime l'Union
européenne appelle au rétablissement du
calendrier électoral initial tout comme
la CDO la Communauté des États de
l'Afrique de l'Ouest peine perdue a en
jugé par la réponse de Dakar où l'on
soutient que seul ce glissement
calendaire permettra la tenue d'un
scrutin libre inclusif et transparent à
propos de transparence nul doute que
d'inquiétante fissur fragilise désormais
la vitrine sénégalaise cette séquence
conforte en outre un avrant constat
aucune nation n'est à l'abri du vent de
régression autoc
qui Balay d'est en ouest le continent
pas même le Sénégal de Léopold SAR
singor et d'abdououf ce pays qui une
rareté sous ces latitudes n'a jamais
connu le moindre PCH militaire mais
semble s'engager sur le chemin miné du
coup d'État institutionnel merci
beaucoup Vincent c'est vrai que le
Sénégal faisait figure d'exemple de
démocratie en Afrique c'est c'est un
c'est un espoir perdu moi je demanderais
bien à Vincent qui connaît ça 100 fois
mieux que moi ce que ça signifie pour la
la présence française qui est importante
au Sénégal l'influence de la France au
Sénégal et notamment sa présence
militaire puisque on est en train de
remettre en en cause les bases
françaises en Afrique pour pour toi
enfinou comment comment là-dessus en
deux mots d'abord il y a eu déjà une
réduction de voilure significative de la
présence militaire française les
éléments français du Sénégal le ZFS
c'est aujourd'hui 350 hommes bon et par
ailleurs moi j'ai la conviction
aujourd'hui que à moyen terme il restera
une implantation militaire significative
celle de Djibouti Corne de l'Afrique et
peut-être à la marge un peu au Tchad
s'il n'y a pas de basculement politique
de de ce côté-là mais il y a un autre
chiffre qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit le
Sénégal c'est euh auot 25000
ressortissants français 25000 de nos
concitoyens or il se trouve que même au
sein de l'intelligencia d'akaroise toute
la rhtorique anti-impérialiste
néosouverainiste pour reprendre
l'expression de l'universitaire
camerounais Hashim bembbé fait floresse
également et donc on n'est pas à l'AV
contre les
Français franç contre la politique de
l'État français et notamment contre ce
qui apparaît comme le deux poids de
mesure de Emmanuel Macron on s'en
souvient condamner les pches saéliens et
se précipiter à njamena pour adouber une
succession inconstitutionnelle et
dynastique on s'arrête là merci
infiniment merci à vous Vincent hugux
Pierre-Henri taboyot merci à vous
jeandominique merci Stéphanie des pierre
allez le communiqué il me reste une
toute petite minute pour vous donner au
fond les noms que l'on connaissait mais
ils sont désormais officiels c'est
Nicole Boubé qui remplace Amélie oua
casterra Guillaume casbarian débuté
Renaissance est au logement je peux vous
donner aussi le nom de Patrice vergrit
qui va aller au au transport et puis et
puis Jean-Noël barreau à l'Europe c'est
bien ça me diton dans l'oreillette merci
ça fera sans doute plaisir à un certain
Jean-Louis bourl qui était tout à
l'heure parmi nous très belle soirée à
vous très belle soirée à vous
documentaire aussi qui commence avec
Jean-Pierre Gratien sommes-nous prêts
pour la guerre Robert Lafond
jeandominique merch dans toutes les
bonnes librairies et à demain bien sûr
même lie même
[Musique]
heure